confinement oblige les gilet jaune ne
manifestent plus depuis quelques
semaines pourtant ce samedi aurait
marqué l'acte 75 du mouvement à lyon un
groupe d'irréductibles a choisi de
poursuivre le combat
à sa manière les précisions de louis
carvalho et serial bouée de ce samedi
il n'y aura ni déambulation dans les
rues ni gaz lacrymogènes ni flash ball
très mobilisés depuis le début du
mouvement un groupe de gilet jaune a
choisi de continuer la contestation en
aidant le personnel médical
pour cela ils ont décidé d'offrir des
plats faits maison aux soignants on a
fait ce qu'on appelle le bonheur de
l'homme cedh et légumes cuits dans l'eau
de coco illustre la citronnelle du
gingembre et on a fait du riz du riz au
fenouil avec et on a fait des infusions
de menthe et de verveine avec des jupons
police c'est ce qu'il faut à pour la
guerre elle et les soldats qui y voit la
guerre pour les nourrir et nous on était
déjà avant les avec les blouses blanches
pour soutenir leurs revendications et
quand ils dénonçaient le manque de
moyens à l'hôpital et on en voit la
preuve aujourd'hui ce que le résultat
c'est que le résultat dont on était
solides derrière on l'est aujourd'hui
mais on ne se rend pas et on le sera
encore plus demain contactée la veille
le personnel soignant du chu de la croix
rousse accueille ce livre insolite avec
le sourire un élan de solidarité
important pour les gilet jaune qui
continuent de dénoncer certaines
injustices voulait gilet jaune
on continue la lutte
parce que tant que roi des injustices
sur un gilet jaune et la justice elle
encore plus criante en ce moment on voit
par le manque de moyens et on essaie de
soutenir justement notre façon c'est
d'apporter un soutien matériel et humain
aux gens qui au gens qui luttent avec
très peu de moyens malheureusement et
moyens sont pas sont pas mis très
clairement et par exemple les gens sont
obligés de se bricoler des masques anti
su trouver des gants là où ils peuvent
alors je veux bien comprendre qu'il faut
garder un stock de réserve qu'on a
besoin d'un stock stratégique pour
l'épauler trail hospitalier pour les
éboueurs aux ambulanciers pour tous ces
gens là mais il faut aussi penser à un
moment à protéger la population
malgré ce besoin d'exprimer leur
mécontentement pour ses jets les jaunes
il est important d'éviter de descendre
dans la rue immédiatement après la levée
du confinement pour garder le contact
il s'appuie sur les réseaux sociaux afin
d'échanger sur les actions à venir
toujours dans l'objectif d'aider le
personnel soignant